all right so back to the west rain and
snow it is spreading across the west
sinking southward into southern
california i've been looking at the
anemometers for wind and through the
canyons and passes of southern
california they've had 40 50 plus mile
an hour winds already so those winds
will be developing for us but the rain
and the snow is piling up in california
with winter storm warnings there we've
got winter storm warnings for central
nevada as well as southern nevada in
place until early tomorrow morning and
wind advisories for us that begin later
this morning at 7 00 a.m and those will
last until 7 00 p.m we're looking at 45
50 plus mile an hour winds for us the
mountains as that snow develops later
this morning into the afternoon
is going to be quite wintry up there
snow levels down to about 5 000 feet so
even the past mountain springs summit is
going to get some snow as the day goes
on 57 for us early sun we've got a
little clearing now but then the rain
will start developing by noon snow in
the mountains and the rain until this
evening probably mid evening at least
nine o'clock and then the system's gone
and then we cool right back down to low
50s temperatures near freezing at night
and early mornings and what through the
weekend stays a little extra cool so be
safe out there today everybody